un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
bienvenidos sean todos a este nuevo
número de nuestro programa cultural un
placer saludarles desde la capital
francesa y ya mismo damos un vistazo a
los temas que les hemos preparado en
esta ocasión
descubra con nosotros la casa de víctor
hugo en parís un lugar impregnado de
creatividad donde se desvelan facetas
desconocidas del autor de los miserables
100 días de revolución las
reivindicaciones de la juventud iraquí
en las fotos de la francesa emilie en
malfatto
movie una nueva opción para ver
películas por streaming con un catálogo
dedicado al cine de autor
y en nuestra crónica musical una plática
con el cantante francés de abidal y de
quien nos habla de su último disco
imagina un nuevo mundo
[Música]
víctor hugo es un monumento de la
literatura francesa y mundial y su casa
de parís un museo que estuvo cerrado
durante 18 meses por remodelación en
nuestro programa los invitamos hoy a una
visita en primicia de este lugar donde
se descubren facetas desconocidas del
escritor quien fue también un decorador
y dibujante extraordinario
en el número 6 de la plaza de voy a la
plaza más antigua de parís se encuentra
el apartamento que víctor hugo alquilo
entre 1832 y 1848 un lugar decorado a su
gusto donde se evoca no tanto su obra
escrita sino más bien las etapas de su
vida
las mujeres que amo sus objetos
personales y sus pasiones secretas el
director del lugar llega o dinei nos
muestra la intimidad del célebre
escritor francés y 7-5 la casa de víctor
hugo no se acerca al hombre este
apartamento es como una biografía a
través de los decorados de cada una de
las habitaciones se evoca su vida antes
durante y después del exilio están sus
muebles los retratos de su familia sus
pinturas y algo que se conoce mucho
menos y que sólo se descubre aquí el
víctor hugo decorador fue algo que le
apasionó y que aprendió en el teatro
y guti
la casa de víctor hugo en parís se
compone de varias habitaciones repletas
de objetos y un salón chino donde se
revela un aspecto bastante desconocido
del autor de los miserables sus dotes de
decorador electrónico de corbata el
víctor hugo decorador fue un artista no
cubista estilo cúbico
me gustaba adornar no sólo las paredes
sino también el piso y el techo el mismo
escogió la alfombra y diseñó los marcos
de madera de las pinturas chinas del
techo es como si estuviéramos en un cubo
en el que cada centímetro cuadrado fue
pensado por víctor hugo estamos en su
universo cargado de fantasía poesía y
muchas referencias
para los dibujos de víctor hugo no se
conocieron durante su vida para él fue
una actividad íntima aunque hoy figura
en el panteón de las artes gracias a sus
dibujos fue su jardín secreto una manera
de comunicar con su amante
juliette e incluso se opuso a que fueran
expuestos el dibujo la pasión secreta e
íntima
[Música]
y de parís vamos a irak a través de las
fotografías de la francesa emilie
malfatto ella captó con su objetivo la
última revolución civil y de aquí en
esas imágenes componen la serie 100 días
de saura que vimos en el último festival
de fotoperiodismo visa poli mar en
perpiñán
[Música]
emily en malfatto ha vivido varios años
en irak habla árabe y ha sido testigo de
las manifestaciones del último año en
ese país es lo que plasma en su serie
fotográfica 100 días de faura palabra
que quiere decir revolución y que resume
las expectativas de una sociedad harta
de crisis internas y de décadas de
injerencia extranjera en irak si tomas
los últimos 40 años hay casi siempre un
conflicto llevo trabajando en era como
seis años y todo ese tiempo yo veía a la
gente como a chantada como desanimada y
la gente que te decía no es que aquí no
hay futuro es el país de la muerte y
esta vez pues la gente si está por lo
menos está luchando que desde octubre
del año pasado del 2019 ha empezado y
tenemos un movimiento de protestas
antisistema se trata de ser tenemos una
sociedad que no funciona como ciudad
corrupta tenemos servicios públicos que
que no existe y queremos la oportunidad
de tener una vida normal
[Música]
en las fotos de million malfatto
numerosas banderas iraquíes y el retrato
de una juventud que eleva los ojos para
implorar libertad estabilidad y
bienestar en un país que ha estado
atrapado en al menos cinco guerras en el
golfo pérsico uno de los eslóganes que
están gritando en las protestas es
básicamente algo que se traduciría como
por la sangre y por el alma estamos
dispuestos a sacrificarnos por ti irak y
ahí esa idea de decir que el país está
maltratado pero nosotros lo queremos
recuperar esas fotos se tomaron en enero
de este año y el 3 de enero
el ejército americano había matado a
casi alemanes y nuevamente era bueno
tenían la impresión de que
es básicamente se estaba jugando a un
juego geopolítico entre irán y eeuu pero
en territorio iraquí estaban nuevamente
en el medio
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con el cierre de las salas de cine los
amantes del séptimo arte se han volcado
a los gigantes
netflix y amazon prime pero en la
galaxia del streaming existe otra
plataforma lanzada en 2010 por un grupo
de cinéfilos se llama movie y ofrece una
selección de 30 películas de autor al
mes este año con la cuarentena movie
abrió su catálogo a cientos de cintas
míticas nos lo cuenta melissa barra
[Música]
los amantes del cine de autoría de las
películas independientes también tienen
su plataforma de entretenimiento en casa
como su hermano mayor netflix movie
ofrece la posibilidad de ver películas a
toda hora y en alta definición con una
selección de cintas que se renueva cada
mes desde clásicos vanguardistas de
hollywood o de bollywood hasta complejos
documentales conceptuales pasando por
los grandes cineastas europeos movie
pone a disposición una biblioteca
variada y selecciones dedicadas a las
grandes firmas del cine mundial en
diciembre se destaca a la francesa
pionera del cine feminista agnès varda
con una selección de documentales
[Música]
movie también es una comunidad de
cinéfilos con una selección colaborativa
y comentada de las mil mejores películas
de todos los tiempos que empieza por el
padrino de francis ford coppola los
siete samuráis de akira kurosawa y la
reciente cinta francesa porque the lion
zion fue de céline sciamma
no se ha hecho nada
una ganga de punzante cappa habló de
falta bloques de manejo
y cada nuevo suscriptor de movie tiene
derecho a un ensayo gratuito de siete
días y la plataforma está disponible en
más de 200 países
[Música]
y abrimos ya nuestra sección musical y
hoy vamos a presentarles a un cantante
que no se ha dejado desmotivar por la
crisis sanitaria se llama david ally de
alguien muy popular aquí en francia hijo
del fallecido johnny hallyday david es
de esos artistas que han seguido
componiendo imaginando un mundo nuevo
más humano y nuestra compañera natalia
olivares tuvo la suerte de conocerlo
hola natalia hola maria carolina imagine
amor imagina un mundo es el título del
nuevo álbum de david a él y de él quiere
imaginar un mundo no se llama imaginar
un mundo más solidario más humano más
positivo y es lo que nos contó cuando lo
fuimos a ver
el anillo los cinemas hay que utilizar
la cultura la música el cine para pasar
mensajes y dar fuerza vibras positivas
en un mundo que no es tan positivo en
estos momentos ese es el objetivo
podríamos cambiar muchas cosas como por
ejemplo en lo que concierne a la
protección animal o del medio ambiente
yo quería dar una imagen fuerte acerca
de un futuro mejor pienso que hay que
devolverle la esperanza a la gente que
vive en la miseria
a través de la cultura siempre hemos
podido aportar un granito de arena por
aquí o por allá
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay una crítica hacia la sociedad y
hacia las redes sociales hacia lo
políticamente correcto nosotros lo
conocimos mucho más romántico y más
intimista usted confirma ese cambio
todavía soy un romántico hay que serlo
el romanticismo y el amor son parte de
mi vida pero ahora yo tengo la impresión
de que estamos llegando al final de un
sistema social de organización tenemos
que volver a lo humano pensando en los
demás todos tienen que volver a los
valores humanistas para unirnos y no
dividir a los otros y si tus ojos
hombres se dividen en su álbum se ve esa
nota positiva y esas emociones a través
de las sonoridades musicales hay un
ambiente muy pop por supuesto pero
también electro y algo si no me equivoco
de rock de los años 80 es actualmente
claro
sí exactamente yo pasé parte de mi
adolescencia en los años 80 y me
encantan todos los sintetizadores
analógicos me encanta esa época pero
mientras compongo no prestó atención a
tal o cual estilo musical intenté poner
sonoridades de esa época ya que algunos
viejos sintetizadores hijos chinos y
sintetizadores mox
al final quise hacer un poco de mezcla
pero debo decir que todo el resto es
inconsciencia pura no lo hago propósito
la inconsciencia es buena pero siento
ser por el buen camino y reflexionando
de manera
muchísimas gracias para todos y para
todos
claro gracias muchas muchas gracias
me dispararon
cuando tu disco
acá todo uno
[Música]
el rechazo funciona puro
que es cuando ayuda
[Música]
i
es pesado
[Música]
gracias natale olivares por esta
entrevista con el simpatiquísimo de
abidal idea y nosotros vamos a despedir
nuestro programa con la música de este
cantante francés un sombrero mate non
para decirles muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
agua
[Música]